every time Trey was on the Letterman
show and you guys made an appearance a
bunch of times Trey would go over and
almost attack Letterman like like run
toward him and I know Letterman pretty
well and he's pretty paranoid
about someone touching his neck or
something cuz he always has neck pain
and I think he thought Trey was going to
jump on him or something but he was
scared shitless of you Trey right I was
trying to get him in a headlock no were
you
no you know the first time we did it I
you know that energy wasn't done yet you
know playing one song is kind of hard
yeah you cuz we wanted all right they
thank you it's like now what you my
energy is like through the roof right
now let's run around the Ed Solan
theater It's the funniest thing cuz the
band finishes playing and then Trey is
like madly running around the theater
and like jumping on people in the
audience and it's just it's like the
greatest bit ever I punted I punted a a
canned ham one
time did Letterman's people ever come to
you and say hey look Trey you got to
calm down Dave nervous yeah every time
oh no sh and then you did it anyway and
they actually told me that that Van
Morrison like grabbed him one time and
threw his neck out and that's why he's
kind of like stay away stay away keep
him away it's I mean it's pretty cool
Ian sorry David if you're listening and
I'm haunting your your retirement but he
was really freaked out by you there's
something wrong with their drummer
that's that's all you need to
know